I DON’T KNOW WHY --
>> Laura: ALL RIGHT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
GREAT TO SEE BOTH OF YOU
TONIGHT.
JOINING ME NOW -- DR. CARSON.
I WANT TO GO BACK TO THIS DURING
THE SENATE HEARING TODAY.
WHERE LAWMAKERS DID PRESS
DR. FAUCI ON THE CONSEQUENCES OF
KEEPING SCHOOLS CLOSE.
WATCH.
>> YOU THINK WE ARE GOING TO
HAVE A NATIONAL STRATEGY AND
NOBODY’S GOING TO GO TO SCHOOL,
IT’S KIND OF RIDICULOUS.
>> HAS THERE BEEN ANY SORT OF
KIND OF RISK-BENEFIT RATIO FOR
THE CHILD?
PARTICULAR RISK FOR MISSING OUT
ON THE YEAR OF EDUCATION?
PARTICULARLY THOSE FROM RICH
BACKGROUNDS.
>> YOU HAVE TO HAVE THE
CONSEQUENCE IS OF HAVING
CHILDREN OUT OF SCHOOL.
I DON’T HAVE AN EASY ANSWER.
I JUST DON’T.
>> Laura: IS THAT A LITTLE
TROUBLING THAT THIS IS WHERE WE
ARE.
AS A MEMBER OF THE TASK FORCE,
WHAT DO YOU THINK NEEDS TO
HAPPEN NOW?
PARENTS ACROSS THE COUNTRY ARE
FREAKING OUT.
THAT THEIR KIDS ARE NOT GOING TO
GO BACK TO SCHOOL NEXT FALL.
>> YOU KNOW, ONE OF THE REASONS
WE HAVE A PRESIDENT IS SO THAT
THEY CAN WEIGH ALL THESE
DIFFERENT OPINIONS THAT COME
FROM ALL KINDS OF DIFFERENT
DIRECTIONS.
AND THE PRESIDENT IS DOING A
GOOD JOB OF THAT.
I EXPECT PEOPLE IN THE
SCIENTIFIC ARENA TO ALWAYS BE
DOTTING ALL THE EYES AND
CROSSING ALL THE T’S.
THAT’S THE REASON PROBABLY THAT
THEY ARE NOT THE ONES WHO MAKE
ALL THE DECISIONS.
YOU HAVE TO HAVE SOMEBODY WHO
CAN INTEGRATE ALL THESE THINGS.
AND OBVIOUSLY, ONE SIZE DOES NOT
FIT ALL.
THAT IS SO IMPORTANT.
AND THIS IS THE LAND OF THE
FREE.
MAYBE SOMETIMES PEOPLE FORGET
THAT.
BUT THERE IS A REASON THAT
AMERICA ROSE FROM NOWHERE TO THE
PINNACLE OF THE WORLD.
IN RECORD TIME.
IT’S BECAUSE WE HAVE PEOPLE WHO
WERE FREE TO USE THEIR GIFTS,
THEIR INNOVATION, THEIR
ENTREPRENEURSHIP.
AND WE HAD PEOPLE WHO WERE
BRAVE.
PEOPLE WHO WERE WILLING TO TAKE
RISK.
UNFORTUNATELY, THERE IS NO RISK
FREE ATMOSPHERE.
AND WE HAVE TO WEIGH THESE
THINGS.
YOU KNOW, WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE
HOTLINES FOR MENTAL ILLNESS,
THEY SKYROCKET IN APRIL.
AND YOU LOOK AT ALL THE NEGATIVE
CONSEQUENCES THAT COME FROM US
EQUESTRIAN PEOPLE.
WE HAVE TO BEGIN TO THINK ABOUT
THOSE THINGS AS WELL.
AND WEIGH THESE THINGS.
IT DOESN’T MEAN THAT WE DON’T
HAVE TO BE CAREFUL.
WE HAVE LEARNED A LOT OF THINGS.
WE HAVE LEARNED ABOUT
HAND WASHING, WE HAVE LEARNED
ABOUT SOCIAL DISTANCING, WE HAVE
LEARNED TO BE CAREFUL ABOUT THE
THINGS THAT WE TOUCH.
SOCIAL DISTANCING, ALL THESE
THINGS ARE IMPORTANT.
AND IF WE USE THEM
INTELLIGENTLY, WE CAN INTEGRATE
PEOPLE BACK INTO THE WORKFORCE.
THIS COUNTRY WAS BUILT ON WORK.
IT WASN’T BUILT ON SITTING
AROUND AND WAITING FOR THE
GOVERNMENT TO DO EVERYTHING FOR
YOU.
>> Laura: ARE YOU CONCERNED
THAT WHAT YOU’RE SAYING IN
STATES ESPECIALLY, THAT HAVE
MUCH -- VERY LITTLE COVERT.
I MEAN, PROPORTIONALLY.
VERY SMALL.
ESPECIALLY COMPARED TO THE
HORRIFIC FLU SEASON WE HAD WHICH
WAS ONE OF THE WORST WE’VE SEEN
IN THE LAST 40 YEARS.
ALTHOUGH CDC CAN GET THEIR
NUMBERS STRAIGHT ON THAT.
ARE YOU WORRIED THAT THIS
RESPONSE BY SOME STATES AND
LOCAL OFFICIALS IS APPEARING TO
BE MORE POLITICALLY-BASED THAN
MEDICALLY BASED?
>> WELL, EITHER THAT OR IT’S A
GREAT COINCIDENCE.
I’M NOT SURE.
I WOULD LOVE IT IF ALL THE
GOVERNORS AND ALL THE LOCAL
OFFICIALS WOULD SIMPLY SAY LET’S
SIT DOWN AND LOOK AT THE
EVIDENCE.
REMEMBER FOR INSTANCE IN GEORGIA
THERE WAS ALL THIS CRITICISM A
FEW WEEKS AGO BECAUSE
GOVERNOR KEMP SAID HE WAS GOING
TO OPEN THINGS UP.
WELL, HE DID OPEN THINGS UP.
HAVE WE HAD A TREMENDOUS SPIKE
THEIR QUESTION MIKE IF WE HAVE
COME I HAVEN’T HEARD ABOUT IT.
>> Laura: NO, WE HAVEN’T.
>> WE NEED TO BE WILLING TO
REALLY SIT DOWN AND OBJECTIVELY
LOOK AT THE DATA AND LOOK AT THE
DATA ON BOTH SIDES.
WHAT IS THE DAMAGE FROM
CONTRACTING THE VIRUS, WHAT IS
THE DAMAGE FROM DESTROYING THE
ECONOMY.
LOOK AT THE LONG-TERM
IMPLICATIONS OF THAT.
AND I THINK YOU WILL COME OUT ON
THE RIGHT SIDE IF YOU ARE
WILLING TO DO THAT.
>> "THE WASHINGTON POST"
HEADLINE, I JUST TWEETED IT.
A FEW MOMENTS AGO.
100,000 BUSINESSES ARE SET TO
CLOSE.
MORE THAN A HUNDRED THOUSAND
SMALL BUSINESSES HAVE CLOSED
FOREVER AS THE NATION’S PANDEMIC
POLE ESCALATES.
THAT’S A LOT OF HUMAN LIVES,
DON’T YOU THINK?
>> ABSOLUTELY.
AND EVERY DAY THAT WE KEEP
THINGS SHUTTERED, MORE
BUSINESSES WILL CLOSE.
NOW THERE IS A GOOD THING.
>> Laura: 20 SECONDS.
>> A LOT OF THE BRUSH HAS BURNED
OFF.
A NEW BUSINESSES WILL SPRING UP
BECAUSE OF THE INFRASTRUCTURE,